Es ist wirklich absolut seltsam wenn man gegen dieses schwarz blick dann blickt man ins nichts
Absolut nichts ist zu erkennen es wirkt wie aus einer anderen welt aber es ist von der erde
walter black das absolut dunkelste schwarz der welt allerdings keine farbe sondern eine beschichtung aus kohlenstoff-nanoröhrchen
Die nahezu das komplette licht schlucken und damit gegenstände
unerkennbar macht ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt die wichtigsten facts wie funktioniert diese besondere beschichtung
Warum steht die kunstszene kopf jetzt mal klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
In der fachsprache lautet der name vertical alignment you pay also vantaa kurz und bedeutet in etwa so viel wie senkrecht angeordneten
Nanoröhren raster und tatsächlich bei walter black handelt es sich nicht
Um eine farbe oder ein segment sondern um eine beschichtung aus carbon nanotubes cnt
es also kohlenstoff nanoröhrchen tatsächlich aber und das klingt erst mal kurios besteht die beschichtung zum großteil gar nicht ausnahme röhrchen
sondern aus frei
Im raum der dazwischen liegt und genau diese zwischenräume sorgen für dieses extreme schwarz denn das licht das auf die nanoröhrchen feld
Verschwindet ihnen diesen zwischenräumen und wird absorbiert und weil so eben nur sehr wenig licht
Reflektiert wird erscheint uns wandte black so unheimlich schwarz auf der hersteller webseite gibt es dazu das folgende szenario das den effekt ganz gut beschreibt
Stellt euch vor ihr lauft durch einen dichten dichten wald ganz viele stämme dann sticht die bäume sind aber nicht 20 meter hoch sondern
3000 meter und das licht das dann noch unten ankommt an dem auf dem waldboden das ist kaum noch wahrnehmen war weil es dazwischen eben
Geschluckt wird und wenn überhaupt gut erkennen kann man das auch an einem stück alufolie in deren mitte sich ein stück wand black befindet
Verknittert doch das nimmt das menschliche auge nicht wahr die falten sind nicht mehr sichtbar dafür, sieht es fast
So aus wie ein schwarzes loch laut herstellerangaben absorbiert wand tablett
99,96 fünf der lichtmenge und ich finde dass diese super schwarz so wirkt als seien objekte stümperhaft mit einem bildbearbeitungsprogramm
wegradiert aber das eben in wirklichkeit die carbon nanotubes haben jeweils einen durchmesser von 20
nanometern und sind zwischen 14 und 50 mühl lang eine milliarde
kohlenstoff nanoröhrchen sind etwa auf einem quadratzentimeter
verteilt allerdings hat das gesamtvolumen also der materie darin der nano welche nur einen anteil von 0 05
prozent an der gesamten beschichtung das ist echt ein quadratmeter wiegt gerade mal zweieinhalb
Ein echtes wunder material also stellt euch mal vor welche gruseligen kahn als oder halloween kostüme man
Sich damit bauen könnte leider ist es aber nicht wirklich für uns endverbraucher erhältlich und abgesehen davon dass diese beschichtung nicht gerade günstig ist
Eigentlich wurde sie für militärische zwecke und bestimmte anwendung in der raumfahrt entwickelt wie etwa
teleskope denn die eigenschaften der beschichtung sind wirklich mehr als
beeindruckend die kohlenstoff nanoröhrchen sind extrem unempfindlich vor allem gegenüber temperaturschwankungen
oder
starken erschütterung aber achtung bei direkter
Mechanischer belastung also selbst ein fingerabdruck würde es zerstören und so muss das material vor direktem kontakt geschützt werden auf geschieht durch eine
schutzschicht oder glas weil walter black ja aber wie gesagt so extrem das licht absorbiert wird die beschichtung
mittlerweile auch sehr gerne in der sensor und messtechnik und bei infrarot kameras eingesetzt aber auch in der kunstszene
Weiß man die eigenschaften von manta black zu schätzen anfang 2016 hat sich der britische künstler
anish kapoor die rechte gesichert selbst zum ärger seiner kolleginnen und kollegen körper macht jetzt
Kulturen constanta black was absolut irre aussieht da man. Ja keine schatten oder reflexe sieht sind erhebungen und vertiefungen
Nur erkennbar und das auch nur schwer wenn man um sie herum geht
Wenn er als erstes neues zum thema
nanotechnologie und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert unsere begrüßung habe ich noch eine kleine überraschung
für euch einfach hier draufklicken und schon geht es los und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genaue glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
wissenschaftlicher durchbruch in zwölf millionen dimensionen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran